bonjour à tous bienvenue en direct sur
les chaînes parlementaires pour suivre
le discours de nicolas sarkozy le chef
de l'état est en déplacement dans la
creuse sur le thème de la ruralité on
l'écouté madame et messieurs les
ministres et si vous me le permettez
mes chers compatriotes
hier encore la france rurale était
évoquée avec la nostalgie
des mondes que nous avions perdu
aujourd'hui
la ruralité est un enjeu d'avenir
pourquoi
tout simplement parce que le désert
français
n'existent plus
il a cessé de perdre ses forces vives
est ce que les élites décrivait avec
condescendance comme le désert français
il sert peuple et
on à dire une population de plus en plus
jeunes et de plus en plus nombreuses
après un siècle et demi d'exode rural
nous vivons aujourd'hui le retour des
terroirs pourquoi
parce que les français dans un monde qui
bouge
sont plus que jamais chez un certain art
de vivre
à la qualité des produits et à la
qualité des paysages qui nous entourent
le développement du numérique et face
les distances rapproche nos territoires
permet de développer des activités
économiques
c'est une révolution
absolument majeur
et cette révolution
exige une refondation complète de notre
conception
de la politique d'aménagement du
territoire
si j'ai choisi de venir dans la creuse
et il semble que je vous amène du monde
c'est si agréable d'être suivi
compte tenu du nombre de déplacements
que je fais je souhaite bon courage à
ceux qui me suivent
et surtout la même énergie
si j'ai choisi de venir dans la creuse
c'est parce que peu de départements
comme le vôtre
ont payé à prix fort l'exode rural la
creuse peut parler de l'exode rural
alors qu'elle connaît un renouveau
perceptible par tous
parce que pendant des siècles
les hommes et les femmes en guité votre
terre
pour aller construire des villes
ce sont les maçons creusois qui ont
construit la rochelle bordeaux ou même
le paris d'haussmann
c'est d'ici qu'il sont partis pour aller
bâtir les villes
entre 1850 et 1950
en un siècle la creuse a perdu la moitié
de sa population
entre 1850 et 1950 je précise à l'époque
je n'étais pas président de la
république
j'aurais dû je sais
mais étant né en 1955 c'était difficile
d'être président 1950 mais la prochaine
fois sur un effort
pour être à l'heure
et finalement la creuse a dû attendre le
recensement de 2007 pour retrouver un
solde migratoire positif
ça c'est une réalité
dont nous devons tenir compte
nos campagnes ne sont donc plus des
terres résigné
nos campagnes ne sont plus des terres
d'exode voués à une lente mais
inexorable
dégradation de leur situation
et au fond ça explique beaucoup de ce
qu'ont fait les gouvernements jusqu'à
présent
il fallait au fond acheter le silence de
populations et territoires qui mouraient
personnes ouf on avait la volonté qu'ils
avaient de mourir
mais la mort devait se faire dans le
silence on accompagnait l'agonie
mais on ne croyait pas au développement
de territoires comme le vôtre
et je veux m'en expliquer avec vous
parce que depuis que je suis élu
j'ai choisi de tenir le langage de la
vérité
à notre pays et à vous mes chers
compatriotes
pas le langage de la complaisance pas le
langage de la démagogie pas le langage
du populisme ceux qui tiennent ce
langage sont si nombreux et on les
entend tellement vous n'avez pas besoin
de ma voix en plus
qu'il me soit permis d'avoir cette
spécificité
la question de vos territoires
n'est pas de la subvention qui va vous
faire mourir un peu moins lentement
n'est pas de l'assistanat qui va vous
s'humilier un peu plus la question c'est
celle du développement économique de
votre territoire et de l'armée
je
l'aï laissé
la question n'est pas de sauver un
bureau de poste où il ne venait une
personne tous les trois jours
une sous préfecture
qui ne crée pas les emplois par
définition qu'attendent vos enfants
la question c'est de vous donner les
moyens d'un avenir économique
vous êtes une population dur au mal
êtes courageux
vous savez travailler et vous avez un
tempérament
que je peux comprendre
j'aurais pu mettre ici
vous ne voulez pas tendre la main
vous ne voulez pas qu'on vous bercent
d'illusions
on vous en a donné si souvent des
illusions
il faut choisir le chemin du
développement économique endogène sur
les forces de la creuse
pas sous une mise sous respiration
artificielle
qui sera débranchée dès le lendemain de
l'élection
c'est le seul langage possible pour la
ruralité
attirer de nouveaux habitants
créer de nouvelles activités économiques
la ruralité
ce n'est pas le passé de la france
la ruralité c'est l'avenir de la france
à une condition
c'est que cet avenir conjugue vos
traditions et la modernité
refuser le monde
est un mensonge
on peut se mettre assis
dans notre fauteuil en refusant le monde
ça va beaucoup impressionner les indiens
les chinois les brésiliens qui vont
immédiatement s'arrêter de travailler
parce que nous on sera mis assis à côté
ils vont être très impressionné
la france refuse demande
alors à qui allons nous vendre la viande
de nos éleveurs
qui va produire ici
et comment on va s'en sortir
c'est un peu comme si vous disiez dans
la creuse à vos enfants arrêter de
travailler
est ce que vous croyez que dans les
autres départements les autres enfants
arrêtons travail et
refusent le monde tel qu'il est
diriez vous à vos enfants dans la creuse
est ce que vous créez dans les autres
départements les familles vont dire
leurs enfants refusent le monde ça va
s'arranger tout seul
si on veut peser dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui il faut le comprendre
il faut y participer pleinement il faut
il joue un rôle de leader pas un rôle de
suiveur pas un rôle de spectateur il
faut s'inscrire pleinement dans le monde
et donner à notre pays les atouts
nécessaires pour être la grande
puissance que la france a toujours été
sert à rien d'opposer la ville à la
campagne
il faut agir sur les deux espaces
et le développement de la france passe
autant par le développement de nos
campagnes que par le développement de
nos films
je disais que l'avenir pour vous c'est
le développement je vais prendre un
exemple
nous avons promu les pôles d'excellence
le ministre richert le ministre
le maire
portent ces pôles d'excellence ruraux
nous avons mobilisé un demi milliard
d'euros pour soutenir
650 pôle d'excellence rurale à travers
la france 650 il y en as scène dans la
creuse cette
la ruralité nous y croyons
et parmi les sept pôles de la creuse il
ya le savoir-faire des tapissiers
monsieur le maire d'aubusson
mais je préfère de beaucoup
consacrer le peu de ressources
budgétaires dont nous disposons pour
financer un pôle d'excellence rurale qui
par exemple va permettre de sauver la
tradition séculaire de la tapisserie
d'aubusson
plutôt que de subventionner des services
publics qui se meurt des activités qui
se meurt pour le simple but de la
laisser en respiration artificielle de
temps que l'élection passe une fois
l'élection passée la ferme et pas
d'avenir avec l'assistanat
et je le dis comme je le pense je
préviens de beaucoup qu'on consacre
l'argent disponible à prendre aux
chômeurs une formation pour qu'ils
puissent prendre un nouveau métier pour
le plutôt que de le payer chez lui à
déprimer à ne rien faire à perdre son
temps et à perdre son utilité sociale
c'est le même raisonnement
on n'achète pas le silence de ceux qui
souffrent
on les sort de leur souffrance en leur
donnant les moyens de vivre dignement du
fruit de leur travail ce qui est vrai
pour le territoire les tout autant pour
les personnes c'est donc un effort
considérable que nous allons poursuivre
et le pari que nous faisons
avec bruno avec philippe c'est le
développement endogène des territoires
ruraux
dans les zones de revitalisation rurale
le dispositif je parle aux élus
d'exonérations fiscales prévues pour la
création d'entreprises a été étendu à la
reprise et la transmission d'entreprises
artisanales alors que tant de petites
entreprises ont changé de mains
nous avons maintenu l'exonération des
charges sociales pour les organismes
d'intérêt général ces deux mesures c'est
encore un demi milliard d'euros pour la
réalité alors bien sûr
revitaliser vos entreprises créé les
pôles d'excellence ça fait moins de
bruit
que la fermeture d'une comptabilité
publique ou d'un bureau
mais est-ce que l'avenir de vos enfants
sera dans la comptabilité publique ou
dans le bureau de poste ou est ce qui
sera dans le pôle d'excellence rurale ou
dans la revitalisation pause entreprise
vous même calais venir imaginez vous
pour vos enfants
un poste dans la fonction publique alors
même que les contraintes budgétaires de
la france montre bien qu'on ne peut pas
continuer à dépenser autant ou dans
l'excellence de l'artisanat de
l'entreprise et des savoir faire de
votre territoire moi je pense moi je
pense
que vous faire confiance c'est vous dire
la vérité et mettre toutes nos marges de
manoeuvre pour préparer l'avenir
pas pour essayer de préserver un passé
dont on sait parfaitement qu'il ne
revivra pas et je veux que nous
considérions nos territoires ruraux
comme des espaces économiques d'avenir
alors dans ces territoires
il n'y a pas que l'agriculture mais il y
à l'agriculture
pourquoi je fais la différence entre eux
que l'agriculture et la grille 2 je veux
m'en expliquer
partout où l'agriculture disparaîtrait
c'est la totalité de la ruralité qui
disparaîtra
la ruralité ne se réduit pas à
l'agriculture
mais l'agriculture est le fondement
d'une rivalité qui peut vivre partout où
la production a disparu des territoires
ruraux par tout le territoire est mort
et contiennent pas m'expliquer que le
tourisme rural où le tourisme vert
viendra compenser il n'y a pas de tout
risque possible sur la disparition des
activités de production
c'est une réalité incontournable
ce n'est donc pas dans mon esprit
l'agriculture ou le tourisme l'artisanat
ou l'agriculture
l'agriculture est le socle
j'ajoute
qu'il faudra dans les 50 ans qui
viennent donner vous bien
augmenter la production agricole du
monde pour nourrir le monde de 70% au
nom de quoi leur homme qui a la deuxième
agriculture du monde la france qu'à la
première agriculture d'europe devrait
elle renoncé à participer à cet effort
sans précédent
d'augmentation de la production agricole
au motif que ça ne plairait pas à tel ou
tel
l'agriculture c'est notre identité
l'agriculture c'est notre ruralité
l'agriculture c'est un des rares
domaines économiques ou l'excédent
commercial
apporte à la france des recettes de nous
avons par ailleurs bien besoin mais
disons nous là aussi la vérité ensemble
qu'est ce qu'on a fait avec
l'agriculture depuis des décennies
on l'a droguée à la subventionnite
oui
c'est une drogue
c'est une drogue irrespectueuse du
savoir faire des agriculteurs qui n'ont
jamais demandé à être des assistés
mais on leur a menti
en leur disant il faut s'aligner sur les
prix mondiaux mais c'est pas grave
dormez tranquilles on compense la baisse
des prix par la hausse des subventions
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé subventions
donc formulaire
donc contrôler
et on a rendu la vie impossible aux
agriculteurs et puis un moment donné on
leur a dit à excusez-nous il ya plus
d'argent pour payer la subvention
voilà l'arrêté est pire certains
gouvernements fait pire ils ont donné
aux agriculteurs des subventions qu'il
n'avait pas le droit de leurs données et
l'europe les a condamnés à le rembourser
beau résultat jamais monsieur le maire
et moi même nous ne ferons cela parce
que c'est irrespectueux du travail des
agriculteurs qui mérite mieux qu'est ce
que nous souhaitons faire
d'abord que les agriculteurs vivent du
prix de leur travail
et de la qualité de leurs produits et
pour cela c'est toute la bataille que
nous menons
sur la régulation du prix des matières
premières agricoles sur les marchés et
ça marche comme j'ai pu le vérifier
auprès des éleveurs ce matin
c'est la défense de la politique
agricole commune mais si nous voulons
défendre la politique agricole commune
elle doit être juste on ne peut pas
défendre quelque chose qui est injuste
et en 2008
nous avons transféré un milliard d'euros
qui allait aux producteurs de grandes
cultures céréales notamment pour le
verset acquis au centre d'élevage
notamment aux zones d'élevage de
montagne notamment ici quand j'entends
dire qu'on n'a pas fait assez pour la
réalité je veux m'inscrire en faux
contre ce monde démagogique un milliard
d'euros a été aux agriculteurs aux
éleveurs notamment des zones de montagne
et des zones enclavées nous allons faire
encore davantage je vous l'annoncé
des prix un savoir-faire des produits de
qualité cela veut dire la compétitivité
et nous avons décidé avec bruno le maire
et le premier ministre que le coût du
travail
sur les emplois permanents des
exploitations agricoles
allait être réduit nous allons donc
diminuer les charges qui affectent le
salaire horaire des salariés permanents
agricoles après avoir diminué les
charges qui pèsent sur le salaire
horaire des employés à temps partiel ou
provisoire des exploitations agricoles
vous voyez la logique de ce qu'on essaie
de faire améliorer la compétitivité des
agriculteurs pour en faire des centres
preneur pour qu'ils continuent à
produire des produits de qualité qu'ils
vendent sur l'ensemble des marchés du
monde et ainsi vous aurez une
agriculture durable qui vivra du fruit
de son travail et non pas du fruit de
subventions qu'on maintient au dessus de
leur tête avec le risque de se voir
supprimer à chaque changement européen
où à chaque changement de ministre de
l'agriculture
je veux remercier le parlementaire
bernard reynès pour son rapport sur ce
sujet je précise que la baisse des
charges sociales sur les emplois
permanents des exploitations agricoles
sera appliquée dès l'an prochain il fera
l'objet d'amendements à la présente loi
de finances défendu par valérie pécresse
et par françois paroisse
ce n'est donc pas une promesse c'est une
décision
naturellement je dois veiller avec le
premier ministre à l'équilibré de nos
finances
je voudrais me dire un modèle
mesdames et messieurs regardez ce qui se
passe en grèce
baisse des pensions de retraite
baisse des salaires
regardez ce qui se passe en irlande
baisse des salaires baisse des pensions
de retraite
regardez ce qui se passe au portugal
baisse des salaires baisse des pensions
retraites regardez la situation de
l'espagne et de l'italie
j'ai tout fait avec le premier ministre
gouvernement pour préserver la france de
cette situation
oh je sais
certains parmi vous ici tu es en colère
lorsque je vous ai demandé de réformer
les retraites
et qui peut être content de travailler
deux années de plus sans avoir une
augmentation de sa retraite mes chers
compatriotes vous demande l'entendre où
en serions nous si nous n'avions pas
fait la réforme des régimes de retraite
où en serions nous
dans quelle situation serait
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui vos retraites sont payées
sont financés le régime sera à
l'équilibré chemin télé c'est parce
qu'avant il fait la réforme des
retraites
il ya beaucoup de gens qui parlaient
et indigènes vous inquiétez pas chers
français
si nous gagnons on reviendra sur ce qui
fait pourquoi ils sont si discret
aujourd'hui
ont ils déjà oublié la promesse d'hier
vous avez une personne qui disait
solennellement je le promène dans les
français on reviendra à la retraite à 60
ans
je vous dis une chose personne n'y
reviendra parce que ce serait conduire
la france à la faillite et ça je ne
l'accepterai jamais naturellement c'est
pas facile de dire aux gens qu'il faut
travailler davantage c'est tellement
plus simple de dire on va dépenser plus
c'est tellement plus simple de proposer
et de promettre n'importe quoi surtout
avec l'argent des français mais à
l'arrivée on est bien content de vivre
dans un pays protégés qui tient sa place
qui garde sa notation et aucun d'entre
vous n'a eu à l'est à la banque pour
retirer ses économies ou être ruiné
parce que les banques s'effondrait c'est
ça la réalité est bien cela on peut le
faire par le travail et non par
l'assistanat par la vérité et non par la
démagogie par le courage et non par la
lâcheté
et par le sens de la responsabilité
parce que moi je crois à la lucidité de
nos compatriotes c'est la raison pour
laquelle les 210 millions d'exonérations
de charges sur les entreprises agricoles
seront financés grâce au produit de la
taxe sur les boissons sucrées parce
qu'il est normal que lorsque nous
prévoyons une aide on prévoit son
financement parce que sinon on conduit
son pays à la ruine et je n'ai pas été
élu pour cela alors je voudrais
également dire que dans la sauvegarde
des territoires ruraux il ya la question
du désenclavement
la creuse illustre parfaitement les
progrès accomplis sur le plan routier
avec l'achèvement récent de la mise en
deux fois deux voies de la rn 145
la modernisation qui se poursuit de la
route centre europe atlantique qui
positionne la creuse sur un axe majeur
entre la façade atlantique et la vallée
du rhône
le grenelle de l'environnement a certes
mis l'accent sur le ferroviaire et le
fluvial mais l'a explicitement prévus la
poursuite d'un important programme
routier d'aménagement évidemment pour la
creuse le fluvial c'était un peu plus
compliqué
enfin mes connaissances sont modestes
enfin je sais ça
c'est difficile d'ouvrir un grand port
c'est certain et là aussi je m'étonne
parfois du sectarisme de certains
comportements
faut développer fluvial faut développer
le ferroviaire je vais revenir
mais il est des territoires qu'on ne
peut atteindre que par le camion
que par la voiture
et ces gens qui sont nos territoires va
pas les empêcher de vivre de se nourrir
d'avoir leurs enfants qu'est à l'école
alors je sais bien que dans certains
congrès de parti politique dès qu'on
sort le mot voiture où le mot camion ça
provoque comme un tremblement de terre
mais pour les gens dans un département
comme le vôtre j'aime le vélo
mais enfin
tout le monde n'a pas ma forme
la desserte ferroviaire le tgv viendra
jusqu'à limoges dans les années à venir
je me suis engagé
le tgv est indissociablement liés au
chantier sud europe atlantique
je veux que des territoires comme la
creuse qui n'auront pas accès
directement la grande vitesse ne
subissent pas ce que j'appellerais une
forme de double peine en voyant
parallèle les lésions ferroviaire
classique péricliter
c'est malheureusement un travers de
notre pays du débat politique dans notre
pays quand on est pour le fluvial on est
contre le routier
quand on est pour la grande vitesse on
est contre les réseaux classiques ce qui
fait que ceux qui n'ont pas de fluvial
est pas grande vitesse
n'ont que leurs yeux ou n'aurait que
leurs yeux pour pleurer
c'est cette raison qui a fait que avec
françois baroin nous avons signé avec la
sncf le 13 décembre dernier une
convention sur en la pérennité des
trains d'équilibré du territoire les
intercités lunéa téoz que vous
connaissez bien puisque ce sont ceux qui
assurent la desserte de vos territoires
ces lignes étaient menacés de
disparition l'état n'a 40e' la pérennité
et nous avons prévu chaire valérie
pécresse 300 millions d'euros pour
moderniser le matériel roulant parce que
je ne veux plus que d'un côté des tgv
flambant neuf et de l'autre la réalité
quotidienne des français dans des trains
d'un autre âge mais là encore nous
préférons investi dans ces dessertes
qui désenclave beau territoire plutôt
que regarder mourir et maintenir encore
une fois
artificiellement en vie des services qui
ne correspondent plus à la réalité de ce
qu'est la creuse aujourd'hui
l'accessibilité des territoires ruraux
c'est l'internet haut débit et la
téléphonie mobile
aujourd'hui 88 % de la population est
désormais desservie par le réseau
téléphonie mobile de troisième
génération
l'état est décidé à aller plus loin pour
la quatrième génération les opérateurs
auront l'obligation je dis bien
l'obligation de couvrir les zones
rurales et ne pourront plus se contenter
des territoires les plus rentables
par parenthèse j'aimerais bien que le
gouvernement s'occupe de quelque chose
c'est à dire à chaque fois qu'on passe
dans une zone d'ombré ça fait une
communication plus à payer pour nous et
un bénéfice de plus sans se voir pour
l'opérateur
alors que celui qui subit la coupure n'y
est pour rien
je veux pas dire qu'il ya des arrière
pensées
enfin c'est une façon d'augmenter la
consommation de téléphonie mobile à bon
compte
et qu'on vienne pas me dire que ça
consciente que la creuse pour circuler
en voiture à paris je puis vous dire que
pour avoir une conversation unique il
faut parfois appelé trois fois son
correspondant peut-être qu'on peut
réfléchir à ce que ça donnerait avec une
communication unique plutôt 3
communications payer pour une seule
c'est une remarque très personnel qui
n'étaient pas dans le discours mais
quelle j'attache du prix
j'ajoute que
le très haut débit pour un territoire
comme le vôtre c'est considérable
avec le grand emprunt
nous mettons deux milliards d'euros pour
appuyer les programmes de développement
de la fibre optique dont un milliard
d'euros sera consacré au soutien des
projets des collectivités locales dans
des zones peu denses comme la vôtre 1
milliard d'euros 1 milliard d'ot élan
corp qu'est-ce qui vaut mieux chez vous
le haut débit qui marche
ou une trésorerie d'un qu'elle vient
trois personnes dans la semaine
qu'est-ce que vous choisissez pour moi
c'est le choix de la fibre optique qui
va permettre de relier
toutes les activités économiques et tous
les foyers de la creuse au monde entier
c'est ce que je viens de voir l'école de
neo que j'évite et visité ce matin et
qui demande que la modernité et dans la
creuse
la l'aménagement du territoire c'est
également une répartition équilibrée des
équipements publics
c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité que la
creuse puisse accueillir une nouvelle
structure pénitentiaire
qui s'ajoutera la maison d'arrêt de
guéret dont nous avons suspendu la
fermeture et que nous allons rénover ce
nouvel établissement accueillera des
condamnés en fin de peine et aura
vocation de préparer plus efficacement
leur sortie de prison je tiens à saluer
mon ami jean auclair janot pour les
intimes j'assure
qui a beaucoup oeuvré pour
l'implantation de cet établissement
beaucoup plus vrai chez jal hausse ça
veut dire qu'il était très désagréable
avec nous tant qu'on a pas céder quoi
voilà
enfin vous avez tous compris mais là
encore ge sur un territoire comme le
vôtre nous avons besoin d'équipements
publics nous avons besoin
d'établissements pénitentiaires
c'est du travail qui est donnée à vos
entreprises c'est des emplois qui sont
réservées
et c'est un équilibre du territoire que
nous aménageons
j'ajoute enfin que
la question je voudrais dire un mot de
la question des services publics
je vais en parler avec vous parce que
c'est une question
qui provoque de l'inquiétude ce qui est
bien normal
et qui déchaîne la démagogie
la ruralité a besoin de services publics
il y avait que dans ma délégation je ne
remercie jean paul bailly le président
de la poste
qui est un homme que j'apprécie beaucoup
et qui a modernisé toutes les
entreprises à la tête desquels il s'est
trouvé prenons la poste
la poste est un service public qu'elle
les gens sont très attachés pourquoi
parce que quand on est âgé ou quand on
travaille le courrier ça compte
énormément
mais qui peut penser
qu'à l'heure où la poste allemande
créer des entreprises de logistique
qui modernise le monde entier gage elle
à l'époque où on envoie moins de l'être
parce qu'il y à l'internet et où la
poste au lieu d'être une entreprise qui
transportait du courrier devient
entreprises de logistique qui va pour
l'essentiel
livre est ce que vous avez commandé par
internet qui peut penser qu'on pouvait
garder des bureaux de poste un ancien
qu'est ce que nous avons fait nous avons
essayé de créer un système
gagnant-gagnant
renforcer les commerçants de vos petits
villages qui ont besoin de chiffres
d'affaires
en leur mettant un bureau de poste dans
le commerce
ce qui permet à ces commerçants d'avoir
ce site à faire en plus et à vous
d'aller dans le bureau de poste
commerçant à des heures
d'ouverture qui sont compatibles avec le
fait que maintenant dans la creuse les
femmes et les hommes travaillent
qu'est-ce qui vaut mieux un bureau de
poste ouvert dans la journée quand vous
n'êtes pas là
où un commerçant un bar-tabac un café
restaurant qui a un point poste qui est
ouvert le week-end et qui est ouvert le
jour et aux heures où vous êtes là à qui
ça a même un surcroît de revenus j'étais
dans une petite commune tout à l'heure
qui n'avait pas un commerçant
est bien le maire a laissé un local pour
le bureau de poste
c'est 1000 euros de revenus par mois
pour la commune
je voudrais dire une autre chose est-ce
qu'il n'est pas venu le temps quand un
fonctionnaire de qualité de lui confier
au même endroit la responsabilité de
plusieurs services publics plutôt qu'un
seul
la sécurité sociale edf la poste la
banque postale au nom de quoi faudrait
t'il un bureau un chef une hiérarchie un
local pour chacun est ce qu'on ne peut
pas faire dans la main d'un seul
fonctionnaire quel fonctionnaire de
l'état la possibilité de répondre à
plusieurs services est ce que vous
croyez vraiment qu'on peut continuer
comme on l'a fait jusqu'à présent
les chers compatriotes la france a
embauché un million de fonctionnaires de
plus
entre
1991 et 2007 un million
je n'ai pas le souvenir que la france de
était sous administré un million qui
paye c'est vous
c'est les charges
que l'état met sur le travail qui est le
vôtre
depuis que je suis président de la
république je l'assument j'avais promis
qu'on ne remplacerait pas un départ sur
deux de fonctionnaires à la retraite
cent cinquante mille postes en moins il
ya ceux qui à paris me réclament des
économies et qui sur le territoire
promettent des dépenses ils
disent la vérité où ils mentent
ils mentent
là encore
nous dépensons plus que nos voisins
comment voulez vous que ça marche
la question n'est pas de supprimer les
services publics auxquels vous êtes
attachés vous avez raison on y est
rattachée
la question c'est de les utiliser au
mieux de les mutualiser
pour qu'encore une fois la même personne
puisse dans la journée vous donnez des
services différents
il n'y a pas d'autre possibilité de
faire c'est comme cela qu'on sauvera le
service public et pas autrement alors ce
que nous avons fait avec la poste c'est
me semble-t-il
l'exemple de ce qu'il conviendra de
faire
quand nous avons dit aux buralistes au
café-restaurant
que nous baisserons la tva
pour la mettre à 5,5
moi je les fais
pour sauver des gens qui concourent au
service public dans vos villages
parce que si le café et je parle sous
contrôle des mers si le café restaurant
le p'ti débute demain
moeurs qu'est ce qui restera dans votre
village
rien
et en mettant la tva à 5,5 qu'est ce
qu'on a fait on a donné à ses 33 mille
cafés restaurants la même tva que pour
la chaîne de restauration
mcdonald's vu que certains promettaient
de la supprimer
mais moi je vous dire une chose
si on supprime cette tva il ya beaucoup
de cafés restaurants dans vos villages
qui disparaîtront
il faudra bien m'expliquer comment on
aide la ruralité en faisant disparaître
des gens qui ne demandent rien d'autre
que de pouvoir travailler dans le lieu
qu'ils ont choisi pour vivre
c'est aussi les maisons de santé
la ruralité les médecins je sais que
c'est un problème pour vous les médecins
mais comment on fait
la coercition n'a jamais fonctionné
jamais
xavier bertrand vient de décider et il a
mon plein soutien que la rémunération
des médecins ne seraient plus simplement
une rémunération à l'acte
je m'explique
un médecin qui acceptent de s'installer
dans une zone où il n'y a plus de
médecin
c'est un médecin qui joue un rôle de
service public
et il doit être rémunéré pour ce rôle
qu'il apporte à la collectivité par
rapport à un médecin qui choisit
d'exercer dans un quartier de nos villes
où il ya déjà tant de médecins qu'ils se
marchent sur les pieds et qu'ils ne
peuvent même plus vivre
pareil pour les maisons de santé et les
dispositifs que nous avons mis en place
alors je sais qu'il ya eu des
inquiétudes notamment chez vous
sur le centre de radiothérapie
indispensable aux creusois notamment
souffrant d'un cancer et malheureusement
le cancer ne fera pas quand creuse et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
décidé de maintenir à l'hôpital de
guéret un centre de radiothérapie dont
j'ai estimé qu'il était indispensable
pour les creusois
je veux que vous compreniez une chose il
ne faut pas d'idéologie dans notre pays
le centre de radiothérapie n'est pas de
gauche il n'y pas de droite il faut du
pragmatisme
du bon sens de l'honnêteté et du courage
la réforme de l'organisation des
services publics dans l'art et dans la
ruralité l'aide incontournable mais ça
ne veut pas dire qu'on ne doit jamais
entendre les arguments de ceux qui sur
le territoire nous disent non trop
importants pas ça on doit pouvoir avoir
un dialogue j'ajoute que
l'organisation des services publics en
france ne doit pas forcément être la
même d'un département à l'autre
parce que chaque département à sa
réalité sa sensibilité son identité
alors bien sûr
il ya bien d'autres problèmes que
j'aurais pu
évoquer devant vous je voudrais terminer
en disant deux choses
la première
c'est de vous parler et notamment aux
élus de la question des normes
c'est une affaire essentielle
tant d'élus sous du craquant bien
français qui fait que maintenant il vaut
mieux construire lait est légal plutôt
que hbo en prenant un risque
quand j'ai commencé mes études de droit
me disait nul n'est censé ignorer la loi
vaste programme
parce que en tout cas moi je peux vous
dire une chose section le droit de
l'urbanisme le droit du logement il ya
bien des choses que j'ignore
les jurisprudences se multiplient la
doctrine complique
j'ai donc demandé un petit groupe de
députés dans la coordination sera
confiée à pierre morel à l'huissier qui
est ici de faire d'ici la fin de l'année
des propositions
de mesures de simplification urgente
pour les collectivités
philippe richert tu suivras ce travail
il est absolument indispensable jeunes
élus fixent aucune limite à ce travail
et philippe le sait
il est des normes
auxquelles j'attache de l'importance je
vais m'en expliquer devant vous et je
vous parle en toute liberté
c'est celle qui concerne nos
compatriotes souffrent d'un handicap
le handicap mes chers compatriotes ça
peut arriver à tout le monde
dans des conditions
de brutalité que la vie c'est seule
réserve et n'importe quel âge
n'importe quelle famille n'importe quel
statut
le handicapé soit il a pas eu de chance
à la naissance
soit il a rencontré la maladie ou
l'accident
s'occuper des handicapés c'est s'occuper
de nous ça peut nous arriver à chaque
instant à vous comme à moi je voudrais
dire une chose je vois ce cas
d'exaspérer la norme mes pensées
si vous viviez dans un fauteuil qui vous
étiez condamné à votre lit si vous ne
pouviez pas vous déplacer
le fait de ne par an pour rentrer dans
un bâtiment parce que le bâtiment n'est
fait que pour les valides c'est quelque
chose d'insupportable
donc je demande aux élus je suis prêt à
voir toute forme d'aménagement je vous
demande simplement avec la générosité
des élus toutes tendances confondues qui
est la vôtre de comprendre que le
handicap mérite notre solidarité
beaucoup plus que bien des gens qui
viennent protester en permanence et qui
serait mieux bien mieux me semble-t-il
serait bien mieux qu'ils reconnaissent
leur chance au lieu de clamer leurs
protestations parce que les handicapés
protestent
enfin je veux terminer en vous disant un
mot de la réforme que j'ai voulu
j'assume des
collectivités territoriales
philippe richert a accompagné dans bien
des déplacements j'ai voulu cette
réforme je m'en explique devant vous
bien sûr
promettre des postes d'élus en plus
c'est facile
mais ce que vous croyez vraiment
qu'en 2011
un pays comme le nôtre
peut continuer avec comme une
communauté de communes
pays
département
région et en europe
sept niveaux d'administration
c'est vous qui payez là encore c'est sur
les impôts de ceux qui travaillent qu'on
finance ces budgets il n'y a pas la
poche du contribuable national et celle
du contribuable local il n'y a qu'une
poche c'est le même contribuable sept
niveaux d'administration
je suis prêt à prendre tous les paris
même les élus
ne comprennent pas où se prennent des
décisions
déposent des dossiers partout puisque
tout le monde est responsable de tout
donc personne n'est responsable de rien
voilà la situation
je vous dis
oui tout le monde est responsable de
tout et personne n'est responsable de
rien parce que nous seulement nous avons
sept niveaux d'administration
mais la compétence générale est la règle
pour tous les niveaux d'administration
comme une compétence générale
département compétence générale région
compétence générale ida compétences
général europe de plus en plus
compétence générale moyennant quoi tout
le monde se mêle de tout aucun élu
d'ailleurs quel que soit son engagement
politique ne peut résister à la pression
tout le monde finance tout mais c'est le
même contribuable en bout de chaîne donc
j'ai voulu
plutôt que d'avoir des départements et
des régions qui font la même chose ou
qui se concurrencent qu'on rapproche les
deux
j'ai voulu faire quelque chose de
j'admets bien volontiers qu'il est très
révolutionnaire j'ai voulu réduire le
nombre d'élus
40% des lieux en moins parce que
j'estime que nous les élus nous devons
montrer l'exemple et me semble qu'il est
plus raisonnable dans la crise que
connaît le monde que nous diminuions le
nombre d'élus et d'échelon plutôt que
nous augmentions le nombre d'élus et
d'échelon c'est le gosier territoriales
qui fera le rôle du conseiller général
et du conseil régional
kara dans sa main les dossiers du
département et les dossiers de la région
j'ai voulu conserver le canton
parce que le canton compte pas dans les
villes mais le canton pour les
territoires ruraux ça compte et c'est
pour ça que j'ai voulu le conserver
alors naturellement je le dis pour les
communes
j'ai toujours pensé
qu'il fallait garder les communes parce
que cela faisait partie de l'art de
vivre français
et que la réorganisation de la carte
communale n'avait pas de sens pour une
raison simple c'est que ceux qui animent
les communes sont à 99 99% des bénévoles
qui consacrent de leur temps en plus
leur vie et qui ne coûte rien à la
collectivité territoriale
doivent être préservés car dès la
compétence générale j'ai demandé au
préfet et philippe richert tu
mets en oeuvre ces instructions je l'en
remercie
s'agissant de la nouvelle carte de
l'intercommunalité
de faire preuve de souplesse
d'engager le dialogue et de garder un
calendrier le plus consensuel et le plus
large possible mais la réforme elle se
fera et vous verrez une fois qu'on leur
a fait personne ne reviendra dessus et
on dira mais au fond pourquoi on l'avait
pas fait avant j'ajoute un dernier point
la péréquation
j'avais dit
lors d'une de mes visites en creuse et y
en a eu beaucoup
je me félicite en va pour moi en tout
cas qu'on ne pouvait pas traiter la
creuse comme on traitait le département
des hauts-de-seine
je le pense toujours
et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui m'a amené
avec claude guérin philippe richert a
créé le fonds national de péréquation
des droits de mutation à titre onéreux
qui n'existait pas avant 2007
au fond ça consiste vous savez que sur
chaque vente de terrains d'appartements
les départements comme les communes
reçoivent une partie des droits de
mutation a évidemment dans un
département comme les hauts-de-seine les
droits de mutation sont plus importants
que dans un département comme le vôtre
je visitais tout à l'heure des logements
qui me faisait rêver c'était 4 euros du
m
ça demeure vide s'installer un d'un
paysage magnifique une population
chaleureuse une qualité de vie
exceptionnelle et 4 euros du m me disait
le maire est naturellement les droits de
mutation chez vous sont moins importants
que les droits de mutation à paris au
prix du mètre carré le maire de paris
l'un des recettes tout ce côté là bon
eh bien ça fait un demi milliard d'euros
que nous allons retirer aux départements
riches pour le donner aux départements
comme le vôtre un demi milliard dont la
péréquation c'est indispensable et et je
vends dire un mot là-dessus parce que
c'est très important mes yeux bien sûr
il faut pas pénaliser les dynamiques par
rapport à ceux qui le sont moins
mais il ya des dynamismes vous n'y êtes
pour rien
les hauts-de-seine la défense à côté de
paris c'est un atout colossal quel que
soit le dynamisme des élus des
hauts-de-seine que j'ai été pendant des
années on n'y peut rien
cette ville de nice que j'aime tant dans
ce département des alpes maritimes
caen la mer méditerranée rendent dans la
ville
vous comprenez bien que c'est un atout
absolument magique ou quand vous êtes
dans les alpes le plus beau parc
enneigées du monde avec les pyrénées
quand vous avez ça à portée de main ça
aide paul maurice les critiques par
l'odeur dans ma situation je critique
personne j'ai décidé de non je dis juste
que je pense
dire ce qu'on pense ce n'est pas
critiquer c'est dire ce qu'on pense
voilà
critiqué
c'est méchant gratuitement moi je ne
laisse jamais été je ne serai jamais
d'ailleurs vous les observez je ne
réponds jamais aux méchancetés ce qui
m'économise un temps si vous saviez
extraordinaire
pas plus que je suis en veine de
confidences d'ailleurs je me demande
pourquoi ils parlent tant de moi
ça ferait tellement bien qu'ils parlent
de leurs idées
ça changerait ça permettrait d'
je ne peux pas considérer que la seule
idée noms de libyens doit bien y en
avoir d'autres et donc il est des
départements enclavé qui ont des atouts
considérables mais qui doivent être
aidés et la péréquation c'est un choix
juste et c'est pour ça que nous l'avons
venu
enfin je remercie le gouvernement et
notamment françois fillon
françois baroin et valérie pécresse pour
ce qui a été décidé avec dexia et le
financement pour les collectivités
locales
nous avons décidé la création avec la
banque postale chaire jean paul bailly
d'une banque
pour les collectivités territoriales
pour que le financement des
collectivités territoriales soit garanti
et je voudrais vous dire une chose
cette nouvelle banque ne distribuera
aucun produit risqué
aucun et quand je vois aujourd'hui
les emprunts auxquels certains élus on
souscrit
je me dis que le bon sens n'est pas la
qualité la mieux partagée
certes certes
certains banquiers
sont très coupable d'abord proposer des
produits risqués
mais certains clients ne peuvent être
exonérés de responsabilité
d'avoir cru à des promesses
inconsidérées et fallacieuse parce que
quand on vient vous expliquer que vous
gagnerez à tous les coups qui a aucun
risque et que vous allez gagner vous
beaucoup plus que les autres si on a un
peu de bon sens on sent qu'ils vont pas
y mettre les doigts voilà ce que je
pense profondément de la situation
ça n'a pas empêché le gouvernement de
nommer un médiateur pour permettre avec
renégociation de ses emprunts mais cette
nouvelle banque des collectivités
locales sera opérationnelle dans
quelques mois
et elle permettra de faire des offres de
prêts bien sûr aux collectivités mais
également
aux pme
de façon à ce que vous puissiez élus
territoriaux
continuer à financer vos projets voilà
mesdames et messieurs j'espère que vous
avez compris que pour moi ce nouveau
déplacement dans votre département c'est
important c'est important pour parler
aux creusois c'est important pour être
sur ce territoire si authentique mais
c'est important également pour parler au
travers de voix toute la ruralité au
fond vous êtes en première ligne depuis
2007 vous regagnez de la population vous
êtes des gens qui comptait d'abord sur
vous-même et c'était une façon pour moi
de dire à la ruralité française et à la
creuse croyez dans votre avenir et nous
le gouvernement l etat on vous y aidera
merci infiniment
voilà pour ce discours de nicolas
sarkozy que vous avez pu suivre en
direct et en intégralité sur les chaînes
parlementaires le chef de l'état qui a
annoncé un allègement des charges
sociales pour les agriculteurs afin
d'améliorer leur compétitivité une
baisse qui sera appliquée dès 2012 et ce
coup de pouce coûterait à l'état près de
210 millions d'euros nicolas sarkozy a
donc annoncé que cet effort serait
compensée par une mesure moins populaire
est la fameuse taxe sur les boissons à
sucres ajoutés et puis la creuse qui ce
matin était le théâtre d'un affrontement
aux airs de campagne présidentielle
puisque martine aubry avait elle aussi
choisi ce département et ce même thème
de la ruralité pour son premier
déplacement d'entre deux tours nicolas
sarkozy a d'ailleurs ironisé sur ce
choix au début de son discours je
souhaite bon courage à ceux qui me
suivent il faut beaucoup d'énergie a
déclaré nicolas sarkozy martine aubry
qui elle lors de son déplacement à
critiquer nicolas sarkozy responsable
selon elle de la casse des services
publics en milieu rural nicolas sarkozy
qui ce matin avait critiqué la primaire
socialiste lors du petit déjeuner de la
majorité présidentielle selon lui cette
primaire est contraire à l'esprit de la
vème république
nous reviendrons sur ce déplacement
nicolas sarkozy dans notre édition de
19h est très bonne journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires